notre panel d'analystes vincent marissal
à montréal michel ces objets à montréal
daniel lessard ottawa messieurs bonsoir
rome la nouvelle vient de tomber
on devait pas parler de ça mais on va en
parler c'est magique
postes canada qui recule qui a vu je le
disais qu'à constater comme tous les
autres canadiens qui avaient un
changement gouvernement à venir donc le
programme de boîte postale vous les
voyez à l'écran communautaire to say
suspendu on met ça sur la glace premier
tour de table vincent bezault entendu
ils ont lu le programme des libéraux
quoi oui denis coderre va pouvoir ranger
son marteau piqueur en voilà une chose
aurait aidé c'est vrai que ça faisait
beaucoup beaucoup de critiques
curieusement les libéraux ont peut-être
moins forcée d'un autre là dessus
pendant la campagne électorale que le
npd qui en a parlé beaucoup beaucoup il
y avait même une campagne d'affichage un
certain moment donné mais je pense qu'il
est sage de la part de la direction de
postes canada devait reculer plutôt que
de se retrouver en confrontation
évidente avec le nouveau gouvernement
parce qu'on disait daniel est simple
vous avez lu comme moi depuis plusieurs
mois on disait que c'était une logique
économique que le monde avait changé
puis c'était plus rentables d'envoyer
des lettres à la maison pour chaque
maison
si vous trouvez une nouvelle logique où
ils sont obligés écoutez la logique
n'ont pas changé le contexte n'a pas
changé postes canada va devoir évoluer
va devoir changer ses façons de faire
que ça plaise ou pas tôt ou tard envoyé
revenir ce que le gouvernement trudeau
va peut-être obtenir ces de temporiser
peut donner l'impression aux gens qui
remplit sa promesse mais tôt ou tard on
va se rendre compte la logique veut que
on centralise la livraison du courrier
et qu'on ne livre plus à chaque porte
c'est ça ça n'a pas d'alluré
économiquement par la chasse et aux jets
sont on est rapide comme ça en nous au
niveau des relations publiques
cc c'est efficace on entend tellement un
choix comme le disque fait ça mais on va
peut-être regarder d'autres solutions
qui était prêté aurait pu être sur la
table et que le poste cadeaux refusé de
faire dans des quartiers centraux de
grandes villes comme montréal comme
toronto faire par exemple les
particuliers une fois ou deux
ou deux fois par semaine ça peut tout à
fait être fait et y rien de
problématique là dedans
la raison pour laquelle parce qu'elle a
un voulaient ces boîtes communautaire
c'est pour les colis or il ya peut-être
d'autres façons de distribuer les colis
par exemple avoir des bureaux de poste
c'est le bureau de poste où moi je vais
chercher des cônes il ay est à deux
kilomètres de chez moi
moi ça me dérange pas trop une personne
âgée que vous qui a de la difficulté à
se déplacer
c'est très loin alors y'a pas la
possibilité d'avoir des comptoirs un peu
partout si les fedex et ups de ce monde
peuvent le faire dans chacun des
quartiers des grandes villes
probablement que postes canada peut
faire un petit enfant mais on a
l'impression aussi qui va avoir une
collaboration meilleur avec les
municipalités avec les autres ordres de
gouvernement la société a des tas n'a
plus le gouvernement dans le dos la
société des postes de plus gouvernement
dans le dos pour l'appuyer pour tout ce
qu'elle faisait là parce que je parlais
de dénis coderre en bout table mais
savent ça crée un réel problème avec
plusieurs municipalités qui trouvaient
que même si sur le fond nous a peut-être
prête à discuter mais c'était de la
façon dont ça se faisait
les mères poules et les conseils
d'arrondissement où les conseillers de
deux villages se retrouver soudainement
avec des boîtes qui poussent un peu
partout ça se faisait sans consultation
ils ont débarqué on installait des
boîtes comme ça et à montréal ou dans
d'autres villes ça peut causer des
problèmes on sait que la population
vieillit les gens vivent souvent dans
des appartements montréal vais souvent
des départements 1 au deuxième étage
vous avez vu comme moi là ça va revenir
je veux pas vous déprimez mais ça vous
revenez les trottoirs glacés les une
glace et hammonds rien et puis j'ai
toujours une pensée pour ces personnes
âgées les gens qui ont des difficultés
qui d'ailleurs est du marché pour aller
chercher leur courrier parfois l'autre
côté d'un grand boulevard on peut on
peut peut-être ça soit réfléchir à tout
ça puis refaire nos devoirs ça sera pas
perdu il y en a un qui n'aura pas ce
problème là de trottoirs glacés à tahoua
devant chez lui justin trudeau le
premier ministre 24 sussex où il est né
ne sera pas sa résidence officielle on a
appris ça aujourd'hui donc sa mère
l'avait pas mal dit vendredi daniel
lessard vous avez suivi ce dossier là
depuis depuis très longtemps chaque
premier minsitre engagé des millions
pour rénover le 24 sussex
ça se fera enfin
pouvez vous imaginer deux secondes que
la maison blanche ait besoin de travaux
importants qu'on ne les fassent pas que
l'elysée que le thème downing street et
des travaux peut se voir travaux
importants qu'on n'efface pas parce que
ça coûte des sous c'est évident que ça
coûte des sous sauf que c'est la
résidence bruits ministre du canada
c'est un édifice patrimonial ça devrait
se faire je pense pas que les canadiens
vont violer saute au plafond il y aura
sûrement des gens d'une certaine droite
fiscale qui enrage chaque fois qu'on
dépense 500 à ottawa mais la logique
veut qu'on répare ses d'édifices là il
n'y a pas le choix ils seulement pour le
show au fait ça coûte 85 mille dollars
par année
ça vous restez en 12 et 15 millions pour
le rénover ça va durer à peu près 25 ans
ma seule inquiétude c'est que si on
confie les travaux à la ccm la
commission de la capitale nationale on
devrait peut-être garde un coup d'oeil
sur les factures michel c il faut il
faut quand même faire une distinction
l'elysée le 10 downing street la maison
blanche et des lieux de pouvoir le
gouvernement y siègent
le cabinet s'est réuni dans le cadre dit
dans un sourire tout de l'elysée rien de
ça au 24 sussex et la résidence du
premier ministre
s'il ya des 10 des dépenses pour la qui
se passe alors au moi je juge bien sûr
c'est patrimoniale vaudois le rénover on
ne devrait pas avoir avoir accouché les
hauts cris parce qu'on va mettre le prix
pour rénover une résidence historique
cela dit ce n'est pas la même chose
nous sommes dans un système
parlementaire c'est tout on a line fils
du parlement quel cabinet ce lait onil
lieux de pouvoir il est pas là ouais
mais c'est vrai qu'on les ait à rénover
un certain certains édifices
patrimoniaux parce qu'on a peur des
grosses manchettes le lendemain même
chose pour l'avion a cédé combien
d'années les premiers son voyage est
qu'un vieil avion qui fonctionnait bien
là mais on n'osait pas mettre dix ou
pour des sièges un peu plus luxueuses
vincent vous souvenez du fameux buste
qu'on appelait le taj mahal walhain
parce que monsieur mattioni chloé avait
racheté 10 airbus ont fait mouche jamais
trouvé ce chrétien l'a jamais utilisée
sauf une fois au pouvoir effectivement
là on a voyagé la dent patrice vous et
moi d'ailleurs dans certaines missions
commerciales notamment moi ça ne risque
pas de savoir que le premier ministre
d'un pays riche comme le canada se
promène dans
l'avion descend on avait poussé les
hauts cris notamment parce qu'il y avait
une douche pirelli là dedans c'est pas
bienvenu ce voyage de toute la nuit pour
aller en inde au japon ou en chine moi
ça m'a fait ce que pour au contraire
qu'ils puissent prendre une petite
douche pu se reposer puis arrivé un peu
trop fripé là-bas que quant à la
rénovation du 24 sussex ont poussé les
hauts cris parce qu'on va dépenser de
l'argent pour le rénover mais quiconque
possède une maison où fait dans
l'immobilier va vous dire que c'est la
pire chose à faire parce qu'évidemment
repoussant les problèmes personnellement
ça va être encore pire dans deux ans
dans trois ans dans cinq ans une toiture
qui est un petit trou ça va quand ça
coule de partout ça fait plus je sais
pas pourquoi on se complique la vie à ce
point là pour démontrer qu'ils sont à la
fin là c'est à s'imaginer dernière
patrice sur le sol l'avion du premier
ministre était au premier voyage de jean
chrétien à l'étranger quand il ne
voulait pas utiliser le taj mahal et
avaient fait le voyage en challenger n'y
avait pas dormi personnes on est arrivé
au sommet de l'otan et quand on a décidé
de fret aérien dans une endroit où il y
avait des casques bleus canadiens en
dessous malacca délégation canadienne
dorment à l'hôtel je n'avais pas dormi
de la nuit dans l'avion
ouais le taj mahal nation comparé aux
autres avions d'aidé aux recherches
restent à jouer daniel vous n'êtes pas
très loin de chez vous le rideau
cathèdre où il va a laissé ses biens au
moment là les grands voisins
non s'il veut pas d'habiter gérer avec
plaisir c'est maintenant à la résidence
du gouverneur général donc c'est très
facile d'assurer la sécurité
c'est un et c'est ce qui a été rafraîchi
peut-être pas rénover complètement mais
rafraîchir peau tellement longtemps
à écouter c'est le c'est pas le 24
sussex mais c'est très bien mais qui
était vous pas bon très bien ça c'est
réglé
on s'inquiète pas mais je vais vous
poser la question sur le leadership des
conservateurs ça se met tranquillement
en branle il me semble il ya pas
beaucoup de candidats daniel vous
n'allez pas me parler peut-être votre
ami en beauce à monsieur bernier qui
veut être chef puis on verra mais c'est
tranquille ou non la berd a dit qu'ils
allaient pas vincent
mais pour le moment il ya plus de gens
qui se désistent préventivement il
monsieur charest aussi leur quille que
pris soin de moi je passais le message
récemment que non ça n'intéresse pas il
veut pas y aller
monsieur mulroney avait fait une boutade
mais son nom avait circulé comme quoi il
peut-être ils voudraient y aller elle
obère jihadjane moi aussi apparemment à
vancouver qui
ça n'intéresse pas trop de presse qu'on
commence à comprendre alors ça ou la
porte de plus en plus j'ai l'impression
jason kenny qui lui depuis des années
fait beaucoup beaucoup terrain s'est
ramassé beaucoup de ce qu'on appelle des
yaoi ou là en fait il ya beaucoup de
gens qui le connaissent sans kardex est
assis riches
c'est un jeune homme il est parfaitement
bilingue la fille le prix des cours de
français depuis dix ans il est très très
très ambitieux et contrairement à
d'autres moi je ne crois pas que sa vie
privée pourraient éventuellement
l'empêché de briguer la direction
d'hydro pour la danseuse malade
daniel est ce que est ce que ils ont le
temps dans le fond ce que ce parce que
ça manque
ils vont prendre leur temps oui il n'y a
pas d'urgence
yossi gal de sénateurs disait prenez
deux ans prenait tout va t'en refaites
les débats de fond où veut aller le
parti conservateur qu'elle sort
d'orientation doit lui donner
et une fois que vous aurez personnes
choisies solidaire qui est capable de
vendre ce programme là il faut quelqu'un
de nouveau
quant à john baird sort est une très
mauvaise idée trop associé à stephen
harper s'est même vue qui accompagnait
madame rappelé dans les événements
sociaux monsieur harper ne voulait pas
aller beaucoup trop passe aussi à une
certaine époque à mike harris et sa
révolution du bon sens sont arrêtés ce
genre de candidat sur l'aide sociale une
erreur monumentale si le parti veut
refaire son image rafraîchir son image
revenir un tout petit peu vers le centre
ouvert servette terroristes qui ont fait
les beaux jours des animaux n'est assez
pour quelqu'un comme john baird dont on
a besoin des cinq années en baissant à
raison représente une image plus jeune
plus fraîches associé steve n'en peut
mais raisonnablement très près des
communautés ethniques vous dis pas que
c'est le meilleur candidat je vous dis
pas que ces derniers non plus mais c'est
ce genre de candidat qui a les
meilleures chances de relancer le parti
mais celle ci conclusion là-dessus
d'avoir trouvé le chef intérimaire ans
et ceux qui paraissent et il a su aussi
aidé plusieurs personnes qui semblent
vouloir y aller
d'autre part
le pq avait parfois un peu le même
problème cette partie des eaux logique
lui aussi en ayant dit peut-être qu'on
devrait se donner une sorte d'embryons
de programmes savoie où on veut aller
nous à la prochaine élection pas pressé
on prendrait un chef qui va marcher avec
ça au lieu de prendre un chef d'abord et
quand on parle bon est-ce que ça va être
le retour des oueds stories est ce que
le parti va essayer d'aller vers plus
vers le centre ou au contraire parce
qu'il ya des gens qui vont vouloir le
tirer vers la droite c'est peut-être pas
durant la course au leadership qu'il
faut régler ça parce que ça peut faire
des divisions très lourde dans un parti
c'est peut-être avant puis après ça on
choisit jeunes très bien messieurs merci
beaucoup
très content d'ailleurs je le dis en
passant ce panel là va exister tout au
long de l'année
ça commence et c'est souvent comme ça
par un panel électorale puis on y prend
goût à cette analyse la politique merci
on va vous retrouver chacun d'entre vous
épisodiquement comme ça merci à douala